All right.
Let's see where we are.
If you were able to get the preview
view controller delegate set up.
Your app probably looks
something like this.
I open up the app to
an empty collection.
I'm able to see my GIFs in a collection.
But when I close out of
the app completely, and
then I relaunch, my GIFs are gone.
So we can check off Save a GIF, and
we can check off View saved
GIFs in a collection.
Now, I know we still need to
set up our detail view but so
we don't have to generate test GIFs
every time we relaunch the app,
let's go ahead and
persist the GIFs first.
In order to do that,
we'll need to be sure that the GIF class
conforms to the NSCoding protocol.
We'll need to save the GIFs
to the documents directory
using the NSKeyedArchiver method,
archiveRootObject.
I will need to retrieve those saved
GIFs using the NSKeyedUnarchiver method,
unarchiveRootObject.